hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
ryan right welcome to 3 minutes or less
for the last week of July 2015 african
american actor Tyrese Gibson has met
with Warner Brothers in regards to
starring in the new Green Lantern Tyrese
Gibson is black with super white teeth
so the green will complement him well
whatever that means brie Larson has
landed a lead rolling Kong Skull Island
you might have caught her in 21 Jump
Street Don John and trainwreck I
honestly don't remember her from any of
those films but she's hot so I guess
this is good news rumor has it that in
batman v superman zack snyder son may
play Robin if you thought Jaden Smith
was spoiled oh you were wrong Tom Cruise
refuses to use CGI jets for Top Gun to
the man is in his early 50s and if he
keeps doing his own stunts scientists
accurately report that he will die in
his early 50s science more tom cruise
news he apparently has an idea for edge
of tomorrow part to the tagline for edge
of tomorrow goes live die repeat which
is a great tag line to describe exactly
what that movie will probably be let's
face it what the [ __ ] else is it gonna
be come on Rachel McAdams confirms that
she has been approached to play a
character and Marvel's Doctor Strange
this goes well with her real-life
personality as she often goes to a
made-up doctor called a gynecologist who
apparently looks at [ __ ] all day
where I'm assuming Rachel McAdams gets
an erotic fixation from having strange
doctors look at her [ __ ] Michael
Douglas wants funnier lines in the
ant-man sequel and after rewatching a
lot of its classic Hollywood thrillers
he'd like to return to his roots and
have intense sex with Evangeline Lilly
plays his daughter I'm not proud of that
one Bryan Singer releases more photos of
x-men apocalypse including a new image
of apocalypse he also defended the
costume design the apocalypse costume
has been compared many times to Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers the movies Ivan
ooze IVA news honestly was a great
villain he inspired my favorite thing to
say after coming use you lose my proud
of that one either alright guys well
thanks for tuning in if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope we're plugged into all the
social networks because we're more than
just youtubers and you could catch my
videos on Latino Review com where
Mexicans are not a minority they are a
priority to the success of the website I
just wanted to rhyme minority and
priority